las vegas finally starting to look like
normal again
today marks exactly one year since some
resorts on the strip reopened their
doors and now
that we're back at 100 capacity there
are some big plans for our city
arko mana shows us what we can expect
this is the most alive vegas has felt in
more than a year we've been waiting for
this moment
and the celebrations are just beginning
it feels exciting and free
there's a sense of overwhelming optimism
in las vegas
one year ago on june 4th 2020 resorts
were just starting to resume limited
operations amid kofit 19 after being
boarded up for months
but crowds are coming back to fremont
street and the strip now that vegas is
at 100 percent capacity
it feels like you know people are
uniting again
because we've been isolated for so long
business is booming again and even more
money will flood into town with the
return of conventions
up first is world of concrete next week
this marks the start
of the conventions coming back to las
vegas ashley lowe is the ceo of
convention people which provide services
for trade show exhibitors she's ready to
get to work
all eyes are on world of concrete this
week they are setting the tone for what
this industry is
like and what is going to happen for the
rest of this year
and to truly kick off this new era the
lvcva is planning a massive fireworks
show for july 4th
seven strip properties lighting up the
night sky we're very excited that las
vegas is back
and we want to make sure that we
announce that in a really big way
it's definitely been a long time coming
but it's safe to say
our city is getting back on track
reporting on the las vegas strip
orca mana 8 news now so a whole bunch of
headliners are also going to be
performing in las vegas for the fourth
of july weekend the
stars studded lineup includes afrojack
bruno mars
miley cyrus and sublime